[Music]
in uh some very uh
guess who news i guess i don't even know
if that's a [ __ ] topic guess who
[ __ ] guess who a husband makes his wife
play guess who i love that game to find
out which family member of hers died oh
okay that's really [ __ ] up and fun
that's so [ __ ] that's a good bit
funny i feel like that's what bart would
do hey dude that's like bart level i got
morals dude that's [ __ ] up i feel like
if they're all old that's not a good
video yeah sure okay okay give the
scenarios where it's okay like if i'm
throwing bart in the mix and it's kind
of like that's kind of [ __ ] up because
that's like traumatic but if like
everybody's 80 on the game they're like
yeah something's about to croak that's
true like you've been waiting yeah yeah
because
my grandma did overstay her welcome on
this earth like we love her to death
yeah but there was a certain point where
we're like yeah damn dude it's about
that time the over yeah
is this a bridge round episode uh no
this is a regular article
careful boys
so i was gonna talk about my grandma for
a second
a woman stole her uh told how her
husband started a sick game of guess who
when he found out that a family member
had died and he wouldn't tell her
directly so guess who distraught woman
goes and shares her story on social
media
um my husband is a stupid troll
this is [ __ ] up for other people but i
would love to play this game if one of
my family members died are you [ __ ]
serious what i mean dude
but if i did i'm [ __ ] no no like like
i feel like it's [ __ ] like let's say
if tid uh if nick did this to tiff i
think it'd be [ __ ] up yeah because i'm
like because she's not she's normal i'm
abnormal so i would like it we know this
yeah but i just think for other people
it's whatever it's on brand
about nick
and we're like
nowhere around like i'm doing right now
i'll surprise nick's dead party yeah oh
[ __ ] i'm not following bart's logic
though
if
you're doing it there's no login doing
it it's not how it affects you if you're
doing it it's how it affects geo or
whoever you're that's what i'm saying
what i'm saying is
you're [ __ ] up but the people you're
doing it too aren't [ __ ] up so it's
[ __ ] up
that's true
[ __ ] up then it's not [ __ ] if you
do it to me if you do it to me about my
dad that's cool but if nick does it to
tiff that's [ __ ] up but you said if
you did it it's cool i don't know i
wouldn't hate it
dick does it to tiff no i think you
would do it really really imagine this
scenario really imagine to say you come
home from a hard day at work and jake
and
his right hand
slaving away
and the jio is like hey bart
somebody in your family died guess who
the first thing i would do is look for
taika and if i see
the game and i would give her mad props
for printing out all these pictures of
my family and then gluing it to all
those little plastic pieces so we pour
half the pieces
and i would say bart let's play a game
and then we whip out guess who and you
flip them all up and it's all family
members and you're just like whoa that's
kind of fun yeah and then and then i
don't tell you at the end we're just
guessing and then you're like oh it's uh
nana stephanie and you're like yeah she
did
see that that's that's that game play
because they gotta start for you gotta
let me you gotta give the premise first
these these are all your family members
one of them died guess which one that's
better that's better that's like this
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] guess who's not
really for me i guess i'm a little more
extreme
you put all your pictures of your family
member on every spot on twister
twister
so you want you want to let fate help
decide well
fate already had a hand in it i think
don't you think ability decide
i can't reach my grandma i'm not
colorblind no you get them into the
impossible situation and wherever they
their ass lands
that and then you're like surprised yeah
that's who died
see
now that's sad i said i don't i don't
play that [ __ ] ass guess who [ __ ]
that's sadistic a little listen
keep your family members alive but
you have to win the game or you're just
like hey guess which one who died and
then guess which one you want to have
died just pick one oh that's a fun bonus
oh we could play battleships c4 oh
that's your mom she's dead oh that's
good boom
or behind one of these closets four huh
c4 with the boom at the end you see how
different board is yeah joke is that
buddy
c4 boom nice i don't know he didn't even
know i like joe's idea to do a treasure
hunt
guess why you missed it because you're a
piece of [ __ ] you didn't check in on
your family member yeah
distraught woman shares a story on
social media said that she has not
spoken to her partner for three weeks
since she played since he played the
game with her instead she had to call
her sister
to discover that her 21 year old brother
had been killed yeah you can't do that
his family member i'm still thinking
about her family member oh that's bad
before she does so that he was at the
voicemail bro he picked it up
so so the one who wrote i lost my
brother in a motorcycle accident three
weeks ago at the age of 21.
this was sudden devastating beyond
measure i lived three towns away from my
entire family and i didn't know right
away
my husband was calling when i walked
into the room where my phone was on
vibrate and charging
i answered and he asked why i didn't
answer my sister's call
i asked why and whether she called him
he said yes and then proceeded to tell
me that he received the news of a family
member's death from her
i was shaking at this point while i was
waiting for him to tell me but he said
guess who
i mean
the woman said the woman said at that
point she phoned her sister guess who or
is he one of those awkward humor guys
you know some guys are like too much
pressure and he just says something
stupid i don't want to give him an
excuse but death is [ __ ] weird yeah
that's true so some people don't know
how to do it i'll crack a joke in a
tension situation probably not a death
one i don't think this was a joke though
to be fair i don't think he like was
like guess who
uh i thought gonna sound like a bad guy
it was like a reflex because how you
[ __ ] read it well dude did you know
that chaplains when somebody dies at war
they when they pull up at the door and
they come up with the thing they're like
you don't really need to guess who do
i'm you we gotta go
april fool's that's the next door over
yeah this is two two one nine right no
oh you have a son at war oh okay
wrong house just knocking the whole nam
neighborhood
i she says i angrily told him to stop it
and tell me but he still thought it's
fine to ask me to guess that's when i
lost it on him because my nerves were
done i yelled at him then hang up hung
up immediately and called my sister and
she told me it was our youngest brother
oh dude a brother love to see her family
without waiting for her husband who said
he was trying to just break the news to
her slowly
i had an awful reaction because this is
my baby brother that i adored so much
and my husband knew how much i cared
about him i drove to my hometown six
times wouldn't know you wouldn't guess
and my husband was mad after he found
out i didn't wait for him to take me
there i told him i didn't want him there
after how he treated me and played with
my emotions like that and he said he was
trying to prevent me from being
traumatized and didn't want to ditch the
news all right defend defend the husband
okay so okay
i thought he had the board game guess
who at least he didn't have the board
game yeah the board game would have been
worse
he's been waiting for her to come home
so he could be like honey i got a game
for you i think it's better green eyes
nope then he gets to gaslight her
because he works so hard on the game and
she does
it because then it's like those
extravagant proposals i stayed up all
night to do this so hard to give you
this you don't even [ __ ] appreciate
me
oh dude
but why did he say guess what why did he
say guess who though we also don't know
the tone of which he said he might be
one of those [ __ ] dumbasses that are
like oh you wouldn't believe who died
guess who even if you said i wouldn't
believe who died that's kind of the same
phrase as guess who you're not gonna
believe yeah it's like hey somebody in
your family died like [ __ ] waiting to
find out but that's her baby brother
though why didn't he just tell her like
like your brother died he's like no it's
not your grandma like don't keep going
closer warmer
you gotta tell me someone died you do it
ready hey hey hey bart what's up
i'm sorry but your brother died that's
it yeah you're not gonna lube it up or
something
yeah i think the only living be like hey
are you uh are you sitting down
somewhere something okay i got something
serious to tell you yeah i hope you
don't [ __ ] crash your car where are
you yeah where are you right now can i
come see you where are you right now
like are you sitting down i got
something jimmy died
that's what you got for me depends on
who it is because for some people it's
like it's like hey are you sitting down
because you're gonna need a springboard
to [ __ ] go
guess who's gone
i don't want you to be already vertical
because you might you know throw
something out because you might hit your
head yeah you need some rough vertical
distance are you driving right now
because you don't want to plug it in
the ceiling i think that's
my go-to would be like
hit nick
hello anthony hold on nick wants to talk
to you
mike needs to tell you something you
know what i would do i'd be like hey
nikki the internet internet commenters
need to talk to you because then they'd
be like why the [ __ ] was he on a
motorcycle anyway i'm glad he's dead
it's good you shouldn't drive
motorcycles doesn't everyone know that
already
dude let internet commenters break the
news dude
oh they should have died
i'm glad they died good more air for the
rest of us
who don't drive stupid motorcycles he's
killing me
why are you so sad people die every day
think about them yeah yeah exactly
[ __ ] comfortable think about all the
people who don't we don't even know they
died
i know we're taking a [ __ ] like
laying in a mirror
guess if this [ __ ] happens don't [ __ ]
say guess who that's all
[Music]
you